when you got to see it for the first
time were you I mean what what was what
was your oh my goodness well when I saw
it for the first time I watched it alone
Rob Marshall was like very particular
was like I want you to see it alone in
the theater by yourself I'm like okay
like the first 20 minutes I was like jaw
dropped and just like tears like
non-stop flowing because you know I
consider myself a musician and singer
first I never seen myself on this big
screen before so it's like all of these
things and emotions of wow that's me
like oh that's a little cringe that
moment there and then also like that's
really me I'm proud of myself